بعد وعود دوليه بخفض الانبعاثات الكربونيه
اتت الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه لتغير كل
شيء فالدعوات لطاقه النظيفه استبدلت
بدعوات لاعاده فتح مناجم الفحم في اوروبا
لتامين التدفئه وحاولت الحرب الاوكرانيه
سياسات الطاقه النظيفه الى رفاهيه لا احد
يتحمل تكاليفها واقع لا يحمل بشائر لاكثر
من مئه من قاده الدول والحكومات المشاركه
في مؤتمر الامم المتحده للمناخ في شرم
الشيخ في مصر المؤتمر المعني بالمناخ
سيركز على ثلاث اولايات المتداخله هي
الانبعاثات والمساءله والمال وهو ما ينقسم
عليه العالم مع محاولته حل المشاكل
المناخيه في المؤتمر تسيطر عليه حاجه
الدول الناميه لمواجهه تداعيات المستقبليه
مع توقعات من قبل الدول الغنيه بدخن 100
مليار دولار سنويا للمساعده على جعل الاق
فيها اكثر مراعاه للبيئه وتعزيز مقاومتها
للتغيير المناخي في المستقبل وما سيحدد
نجاح المفاوضات من عدمه هو استحداثه صندوق
منفصل خاص بالخسائر والاضرار وهي تعويضات
تدفع عن الاضرار المناخيه التي لا عودت
عنها
يتزامن المؤتمر مع اجواء تشهد عده ازمات
مترابطه من حرب اوكرانيا والضغوط التضخميه
واحتمال حصول ركود عالميه فضلا عن ازمات
الطاقه والغذاء والتنوع الحيوي لتزداد
الضغوطات بعدما اتفقت الدول في المؤتمر
الذي اقيم في كلاسكو لعمل ماضي على اعطاء
الاولويه لخفض التلوث الكربوني وتعزيز
الانتقال الى مصادر طاقه المتجدده رشا
خياطه العربيه